moro aqui né
vou
cadê o
carro
é
60 watts
pô não tem mais né
sal com leite
Música
Obrigado.
Não tem problema.
Mesmo eu não sei se tem fogo, se tem nada.
Tem que ter, não tem problema.
É.
É, eu sei que está ganhando grana, eu não sei se vou lá.
Você vai ganhar, você fala assim.
Você vai ganhar, eu falo assim.
não há
ainda não
nunca ensinando para ir ao limite
no caso chega na piscina
mas ele já foi para a minha revisão, para virar
para tirar as fotos que tinha aqui
para a gente
enfim
assim, não estou
participando dessa conta aí
mas aí foi ele mesmo
que me dá esse dinheiro
é só assim, aquela do banheiro
foi bem algo
do dia 1 a 11.
Esquecendo, né?
Esquecendo agora.
Desligada?
Sim, aí tá lá no cubo, olha aí.
Ah, deve ter arrochado.
É um dos.
A unidade dela é gostar da polícia, né?
É, tá arrochado.
Tá?
Certo.
É só arrochar.
Você não acha que tem que colocar...
Pela música.
É, tá bom.
Eu vou dar um revólver.
A gente vai dar um revólver nesse negócio.
Tem um?
Não, não.
Não tem um.
Não tem um?
Não tem?
Não tem.
Não tem um.
Tá vendo?
Phonem? Phonem.
Você já tem nao?
Tem, tem, tem.
Bom, acho que não sei.
É longa pra gente, também.
Só que eu não sei nessa grande...
Oh, Grindr.
Ainda pra Grindr View.
E aí, vc tá bem?
Oh...
Tá triste.
Vai se molhar, não?
Boa!